всі Кошти які вкрадені покидками вони
вкрадені в української армії Адже всі
наші податки які зібрані всередині
країни ідуть виключно на сектор оборони
на жаль в цьому бюджеті попри те що
заявлено що це бюджет воюючої країни а
не все так просто там написано дуже
чітко що сектор безпеки і оборони
безпеки оборони і о це слово безпеки
закладається підвищення видатків на
репресивні органи от мабуть Всі ви
отримали отаку дуже цікаву СМСку що ми
розпочинаємо боротьбу з корупцією
корупція важлива складова Перемоги від
дбр дбр є гроші на ро розсилку оцих СС
такдбр Почніть будь ласка з ваших
представників у Львові які весілля за 1
млн доларів влаштовують цей пір під час
чуми Почніть з себе і саме на оцей дбр
на те щоб вони СМСки розсилали ви за
накладаєте в бюджеті на 24й рік кошти а
в той час як в Збройних силах України на
6% зменшується фінансування в 24 році це
є неприпустимим Я хочу нагадати що
Президент Зеленський свою кар'єру
президентську почав з важливої обіцянки
боротьби з олігархами що ви закладаєте в
другий вже бюджет воюючої країни
фінансування олігархічних каналів 2 млрд
грн ідуть на марафон марафон в якому му
сьогодні залишаються 1+1 який належить
родині медведчуків і іншим олігархам
інші канали які належать олігархам в
олігархів гроші закінчилися в той час
коли ви закладаєте їм в бюджет зменшення
плати сьогодні за ренту і інші видатки
тому наші поправки на яких європейська
Солідарність буде наполягати це
перенаправити 2 млрд грн з марафону
Нікому не потрібно з олігархічних
каналів зброні сили України ви
закладаєте 170 млн на канал Рада який не
показує парламент ви знаєте що зарплата
директора телеканала рада більше ніж в
депутатів і спікера Вона складає
94 000 грн на місяць зарплата директора
телеканала рада І за це ви зараз будете
голосувати це Вибачте будь ласка більше
ніж солдатів на передовій Це ненормально
тому наша команда вимагає зменшити ці
кошти забрати кошти в каналради не
показує парламент і ви за це
прого